If you would like to venture out and use your skills to start your own business,...
...there are, of course, possibilities.
As a good writer, you could start out providing a resume writing service...
...and go on to freelance writing and public relations.
If you have an eye for photography, you could advertise services for weddings and parties.
If you are experienced with layouts and designs, you could try your hand at desktop publishing.
If you can produce crafts or you have a lot of unnecessary things, you could sell them on websites.
But a good business idea alone does not guarantee success...
...and having your own business is not for everyone.
You need additional skills.
Broadly speaking, there are four traits that successful entrepreneurs have in common.
They are personal skills, interpersonal skills, critical and creative thinking skills and practical skills.
You also need to evaluate if your business idea is actually feasible within present market conditions.